so what's something that you've maybe
attempted to make but it didn't quite
work out
good
so many things i'm not i'm not crafty in
that way i like to cook and that's where
i i feel a little bit more confident but
as far as making things i feel like
i can't even think of what i've tried to
make and then fail that but you know
nick offerman has made me some beautiful
things and i i kept it nearby my uh um
desk because i want to show i have never
showed this on camera is that a bad
person oh it's oh
that's amazing i couldn't see i only saw
the stick at first the stick part of it
that's amazing he just gave me a stick
he gave me this beautiful
it's an stick crafted canoe paddle and
the real beauty of it is it's made out
of the doors
on the set of parks and red no way
that's so sweet i love a thoughtful kid
[Applause]
yeah
what
a
she's so sweet he's so great um but you
and you and nick work together in parks
and rec like you were talking about so
is it true that you did ride-alongs with
park officials for research is that real
i did it for like one day and then i was
like oh we got this we i was like i get
it um yeah we did we did i i worked i i
i got the pleasure of kind of shadowing
um a parks and rec employee and it was
really fun because what's so fun about
that show is still people come up to me
and they're like man you really got the
library right you know
a bunch of jerks he's like oh we we just
made that up but i guess the library is
filled with homicidal maniacs um that
run it um no but um yeah yeah i got to
do that was really fun that was as close
as i got to doing any kind of like cool
ride along
[Music]
you